must you behave so much like children so
I kind of want to talk a little bit
about something that comes up in the
comment section every now and then which
is that sometimes I will describe a
Doctor Who episode or an element in an
episode as being too silly and anytime I
do that I can be guarantee there's at
least gonna be a handful of comments of
people saying something to the effect of
Doctor Who's supposed to be silly or
you're okay with what goes on in this
episode but not this one how is this any
sillier or things of that nature
so I kind of want to address at least my
own assessment of Doctor Who's
relationship with being silly because
let's first openly acknowledge it is a
bit of a silly show and part of that has
to do with the nature of ridiculous
high-concept sci-fi premises they
honestly tend to be a bit silly and then
there's also the fact that it was
originally originally designed as a kids
show at this point I would consider a
family entertainment so there is an
element of that as well and often times
when writers can't think of another way
to do it they will get silly and
ridiculous as an appeal to a younger or
a family audience so silliness is kind
of baked into this at least to a certain
degree certainly now but I think that's
part of the thing I feel like the show
tries to be deliberately silly a bit
more now in modern whoo than it used to
because at least for the classic whoo
that I've taken in I'm still filling in
gaps it's gonna be a while until I've
seen all of classic who the thing is
though that most classic hood that I've
seen even at its silliest is presenting
it as serious whereas modern Doctor Who
not always but sometimes presents it
selling
as silliness and I think that's the
thing when I say that something is a bit
too silly I usually mean more the
execution rather than the concept
because pretty much all these concepts
are silly but by and large when it over
steps and it feels silly as opposed to
feels fun comes down to the execution
there are some things that are one-off
just ridiculousness and I can usually
roll with that assuming that it doesn't
like derail the whole thing like it
threw me off a little bit in the woman
who lived that the alien and that looked
like a Thundercat that threw me off a
little bit but you know whatever it's a
cat alien we've had cat aliens before
fine is it a little silly yes but it's
not so silly that it takes me out so I
think a good example for something where
it's presented as silly is love and
monsters because I think when silly
works assuming that it's more than just
like a joke like a single one-off joke
although even sometimes those can get
too silly I might get to that too is
it's not a is it works best when despite
the silliness the the show and the
characters had take this seriously
because often times there's a lot of
silliness put in that is inherent in the
villains the threat things like that so
the characters need to take that
seriously because if they act like the
threat is silly then what are the stakes
why do we care so coming back to loving
monsters you could certainly argue that
the characters you know in Lynda who are
you know the guy who's actually fleeing
the absorb all off is taking the series
because his life's in danger but that's
not enough because the way it's
presented
the way the absorb lava is played the
way he shot the way he lumbers in broad
daylight mm-hmm the way they have an
extended joke about what to even call
him the way the doctor kind of smirks
and snarks the fact that they the dr.
Andros only show up because this guy
irritated or annoyed roses mother not to
actually stop this thing it makes it
silly and incidental and in a way that
doesn't draw you in but in a way that
well nothing about this is being taken
seriously the show isn't taking it
seriously the heroes aren't taking it
seriously the monster doesn't seem to
take himself seriously and I'm not
saying that can never work in any medium
but that to me is too silly for Doctor
Who to work so not everybody does but I
personally quite liked the episode
robots of Sherwood and there's a lot of
silliness in that I mean it's got the
line I'm the doctor and this is my spoon
that's incredibly silly the way Robin
Hood behaves and his Merry Men Behaving
all is very silly but the way that that
causes things to happen in the episode
is it brings a bitter annoyance out of
the doctor so he's not just looking at
this and rolling his eyes and not taking
it seriously he's reacting to it and
then of course the threat is a
legitimate threat and the silliness in
that case is kind of separate from the
threat now I said when the show gets too
silly it's usually or when I feel it
gets too silly all this is opinion by
the way but if that wasn't clear alright
but when I say that it gets too silly I
usually mean this idea is too silly fear
her kind of falls under the same thing
to a certain degree in that case they
actually did take it quite seriously but
it that was a case where the inherent
idea of just a scribbled monster
well it felt like a goosebumps episode
the concept felt too silly and I suspect
for a lot of people they felt and I'm
projecting here because I actually liked
this episode but I think a lot of
people's issues with closing time is a
combination of the concept of Cybermen
under a mall being too silly coupled
with the inherent silliness of having
Craig back and again that one worked for
me but I suspect that's part of the
reason people don't like that but
sometimes there are specific moments
that themselves are too silly even if
the overall concepts aren't and I think
the best example of that is actually in
the very first episode of the revised
series it's in Rose and it's when the
trash bin eats Mickey and it's not it's
not silly because the CGI is wonky
because it's Doctor Who
yeah the effects are wonky sometimes and
the reason it's silly is because the
trash can burps what and that and that
is taking it because I mean classic who
would have played that as a horror
moment Mickey would have you know scream
aah and it just would have been and he's
gone and we're not entirely sure what
happened and that moment would not have
been played for comedy now you could say
it's so silly that they might as well
lean into it but for me having the thing
burp is it's a step too far
that's that is trying to hang a
lampshade on your inherent silliness and
if I use that phrase sometimes if you're
not familiar with the phrase the the
idea of lampshade hanging is that
something is off something is not
working but rather than fix it you draw
attention to it in a way that kind of
lets you off the hook for it so I mean
where the idea comes from is you know
you have this thing in you know in a
room that doesn't belong you just stick
a lampshade on it and it now you've now
drawn attention the fact that it's out
of place and people are like oh you made
a thing out of it okay
get it now that's sort of the idea of
lampshade hanging but the inherent
problem with lampshade hanging is you
didn't fix the problem you just got
weird and ironic and snarky about it and
you can't get away with that sometimes
but generally at least for me lampshade
hanging fails more often than it
succeeds because if something is so
ridiculous that you need to take that
approach to make it palpable maybe go
back to formula so that it's a little
less ridiculous in the first place so
that you don't have to make a joke out
of it in order for it to work so doctor
who is a silly show it will always be a
silly show it should be a silly show it
can also be a very dark and serious show
and I appreciate that but when it over
leans on it and another episode cut I've
got a lot of the worst examples for me
are in Davis's run and especially in
series 2 and I don't need to be picking
on Davies but I mean fair's fair he did
silly a lot more than Moffat did silly
and that's not me saying Moffat is
automatically better Moffat had his own
issues but being too silly was rarely
one of them being too complicated and
take himself too seriously that could be
a problem but you know that's opposite
side of the coin so with something like
the idiots Lantern I know people have
said that there that I I can't relate to
this because I'm American and I'm
prepared to accept that but I can only
speak from my perspective and from my
perspective the father in that episode
is so over-the-top blustering caricature
cartoonish that the whole thing becomes
silly rather than you know somebody oh
just going a little bit too far to
protect his reputation and his sense of
authority in the home it is played so
big that it becomes ridiculous it
becomes silly and in that case it
removes a fair amount of the stakes eh
he's soaked
to nurse there's to me no catharsis when
when people stand up to him because he's
ridiculous it he he feels unreal that's
what makes that silly in addition to the
fact that the wire does almost nothing
except golfy God the number of times she
repeats that I can't again it makes it
silly and I actually really like the
concept of the wire but the execution is
very very silly and sometimes silly work
silly works in doses I think oftentimes
when silly works best as when there's an
acknowledgment of the silliness of a
specific scenario a specific moment a
specific setting but probably best not
to have the villain the threat be silly
because that's kind of what I keep
coming back to because the the burping
trashcan that's supposed to be a threat
but it's made silly the scribble monster
supposed to be a threat adds to silly
the absorber lofts supposed to be a
threat it's played silly the wire and
that father
they're supposed to be threats they're
played silly and I just think that to
balance the elements of dark drew
because there's a lot of play in Doctor
Who because there is tinges of horror
and death and social commentary and
don't tell me like its new like I have a
whole video explaining why there's
always been social and political
commentary in this show but you know
there's there's that and there is a
playfulness there's all these elements
and balancing them is very very
difficult and I think at times things do
get so and they can get too silly it is
possible to be too silly it's possible
to be too serious it's possible to lean
too hard into the horror I would say
that that was part of what was wrong
with sleep no more to the point that
actually ate a trendy gimmicky horror
gimmick in terms of how it was shot so
any one of these elements can be over
leaned on but
none of them should be dropped I would
never argue get rid of all the silliness
and Doctor Who because it's part of the
identity of the show but it can't
overstep and for me when the show gets
too silly it's one of the more painful
things to have to sift through so for
some reason for me for all the over
steps and over emphasis that the various
elements of Doctor Who can sometimes get
from episode to episode over emphasizing
the silly just grates me a bit more than
over over emphasizing the emotional
dramatics the horror elements even the
political messaging which can get
heavy-handed and can be distracting but
ultimately I get more annoyed when I've
just filled this is too silly but that's
me this ramble had probably less of a
point even than I usually have talking
about Doctor Who but hey what are you
gonna do what are your thoughts what do
you think about when doctor who gets
silly what do you think are some of the
silliest moments of Doctor Who whether
they worked for you or not or are there
other things that doctor who has a show
sometimes overemphasizes that you think
is a bigger offense than being too silly
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do you know what it is I've got a
patreon that's kind of a big one but
there are links to that and a whole
bunch of other stuff down in the
description so remember folks the
council is all of you I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]